-Performing "POF"
and "Waste My Time"
from her new album,
"age/sex/location,"
please welcome Ari Lennox!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Hey ♪
♪ Hey ♪
♪♪
♪ "Destined for greatness"
is always what my mama said ♪
♪ Young Black woman approachin'
30 with no lover in my bed ♪
♪ Cannot settle,
I got standards ♪
♪ NASCAR racin' in my head ♪
♪ Independent,
not dumbin' down ♪
♪ Everything that makes me... ♪
♪ The nerve of you
to think I was ♪
♪ Gon' sell my house
to live in yours ♪
♪ You out your mind,
I did them tours ♪
♪ I picked them floors,
so miss me ♪
♪ When you come around,
you're pressin' me ♪
♪ Like Ginuwine "So Anxiously" ♪
♪ With super thirsty energy ♪
♪ Like you never had no... ♪
♪ So what's that they say
back in the day? ♪
♪ "It's plenty of fish
in the sea" ♪
♪ Will somebody explain
what's with these lame ♪
♪ Fish that be swimmin' to me? ♪
-♪ Swim ♪
-♪ So what's that they say
back in the day? ♪
♪ "It's plenty of fish
in the sea" ♪
♪ Will somebody explain
what's with these lame ♪
♪ Fish that be swimmin'
to me? ♪
-♪ Me ♪
-♪ It's the catfishin' ♪
-♪ Hey ♪
-♪ All cap... hat-fishin' ♪
-♪ Why I don't see no picture
with your hat missin'? ♪
-♪ Hey ♪
-♪ Rugrat prison ♪
♪ Bare flippin' five kids,
but you're back pimpin' ♪
♪ See, Lord knows ♪
♪ I don't need no one ♪
-♪ Said, I swear he knows ♪
-♪ But sure would be sweet ♪
-♪ Yeah ♪
♪ See, Lord knows
I don't need no one ♪
-♪ Said, I swear He knows ♪
-♪ But sure would be sweet ♪
♪♪
♪ Oooh-ah, oooh-ah, oooh-ah ♪
♪ Oooh-ah, oooh-ah, oooh ♪
♪♪
♪ The no making me stupid ♪
♪ No funny Valentine lovin'
from Cupid ♪
♪ Need someone to get to it ♪
♪ I see you begging,
so there ain't no choosing ♪
♪ There must be a glitch
in my phone ♪
♪ I'm ready for the switch
to turn me on ♪
♪ Come do something wrong
to me ♪
♪ Cause I'm tryna' have you ♪
-♪ Waste my time ♪
♪ Get on my line ♪
-♪ I ♪
-♪ Cause I got the time
to waste ♪
-♪ Hey ♪
-♪ Use that mouth ♪
♪ Blow this back out ♪
-♪ Hey ♪
-♪ Back up every word you say ♪
-♪ Say sock it to me ♪
-♪ Waste my time ♪
♪ Get on my line ♪
-♪ Sock it to me ♪
-♪ Then you can be on your way ♪
-♪ Hey ♪
-♪ Use that mouth ♪
♪ Pull a track out ♪
-♪ I ♪
-♪ Back up every word you say ♪
-♪ Said every word ♪
-♪ Every word ♪
♪ Baby, back up every word ♪
-♪ I, I, oh ♪
-♪ Back up every word you say ♪
-♪ Said every word ♪
♪ Baby, back up every word ♪
-♪ I, I, oh ♪
-♪ Every word ♪
-♪ Ay, ay ♪
-♪ That you say ♪
-♪ Yeah ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, my goodness!